depuis ce matin mais à huis clos patrick
dils est rejugé par la cour d'assises
dès mineurs de la marne pour un double
meurtre d'enfants meurtre commis en 1986
double meurtre dont il se dit innocent
c'est une première judiciaire du un
élément nouveau la présence du tueur en
série francis heaulme sur le lieu des
crimes au moment des faits le procès
ouvert aujourd'hui devrait se prolonger
jusqu'au 28 juin
compte rendu d'audience valérie ermite
fanni au vernis et raymond châtelard un
procès exceptionnel hors du commun
appuyé d'un titre un procès en révision
rarissime dans les annales judiciaires
le second procès d'un homme qui se dit
innocent et qui a passé près de 15 ans
de sa vie en prison
lorsque patrick dils ce matin prend la
parole c'est pour réclamer que ce procès
là soient publics pour que je cite tout
le monde sache et entendre la vérité
c'est un procès qui est exemplaire à
tous niveaux pour l'histoire la justice
pour le cas individuels de patrick dils
je lirai pour les libertés fondamentales
liberté du citoyen donc je crois qu'un
procès aussi important que celui là qui
est quand même une première en semblant
dans l'histoire de la justice un procès
de cette taille là ne peut pas être
libre donc une société démocratique
mais la cour d'assises de reims a refusé
que l'audience soit publique en vertu de
l'ordonnancé de 45 régissant les mineurs
patrick dils est certes aujourd'hui un
adulte de 31 ans mais il n'avait que 16
ans au moment des faits son nom qui
figuraient jusque là sur la porte de la
salle d'audience est vite cacher le
procès aura lieu à huit clos même ses
initiales logiquement ne devrait pas
être prononcé un second procès
exceptionnellement douloureux aussi pour
les familles des victimes sont tenus par
des psychologues
un deuil toujours impossible à faire
quinze ans après les faits
imaginez les parents qui sont là au
premier plan et à qui on reparle
et comment les kids les conditions de
leur enfant les commissions de mort de
leur enfant se sont déroulées sans
public et sans journalistes les débats
ont commencé à la barre un défilé
d'experts psychiatres et psychologues
chargés de dire si patrick dils a pu
passer des aveux parce qu'il était à
l'époque particulièrement influençable
une question essentielle de ce procès
sur laquelle certains experts divergent
et que d'autres ne veulent pas tranché